it what's up everybody I want you to
enjoy my brand-new badass trailer for
rampaging when I say badass I'm talking
about badass those monsters don't stop
Big Daddy roll the clip someone's
mutating animals into monsters
what the was that you can't put up the
graphic I'm running for my life come on
dude the world is watching this I'm the
most badass movie star on the planet
alright I've got a reputation to protect
now show the other clip the no fear clip
dude
[Music]
just you're gonna have the time of your
life enjoy rampage rampage rated pg-13
a rescue George from he was 2 years old
he's not just a friend he's family got
your message about Georgie okay I don't
know George
assume ears he considerably bigger no
he's definitely bigger what's happening
to my friend are you familiar with
genetic editing someone's mutating
animals into monsters your oversized
monkey is old news
[Music]
of course the wolf flies
let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't fight it
[Music]
you know there are other ways of dealing
with people right I do know that yeah
but that's no fun
rampage experienced it in IMAX April
20th